[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans sens public on est
ensemble pendant 90 minutes pour donner
du sens à l'actualité grâce à nos
experts depuis samedi vous êtes nombreux
à chercher à comprendre le dessous des
cartes au Proche Orient on tente tous
les soirs de répondre à vos
interrogations à vos inquiétudes aussi
le siège complet de Gaza continuera tant
que les otages ne seront pas rentrés
chez eux le gouver ement israélien a
défini ses conditions pour mettre fin au
blocus en attendant les bombardements
continu et visent de nouvelles cibles
les deux principaux aéroports syriens
ont été mis hors service aujourd'hui
faisant craindre une régionalisation du
conflit
on il existe de sérieuses possibilités
pour que la situation se détériore et
que le champ des confrontations
s'étende des possibilités que je
souhaite ne pas voir se concrétiser car
pourrait précipiter toute la région vers
un destin
inconnu et malheureusement les choses
semblent aller dans ce sens la riposte
militaire la situation à Gaza le sort
des otages notamment français ce seront
les principaux thèmes de notre première
partie d'émission et puis notre second
débat sera centré autour du Nouvel Ordre
Mondial les questions posées depuis des
mois après l'invasion de l'Ukraine par
la Russie trouve un écho évident au
Proche Orient la guerre mondialisée
vient vient-elle d'ouvrir un nouveau
front quel pays pourrait servir de
médiateur pourquoi l'Occident n'a plus
les clés quel rôle la Chine pourrait
jouer dans les prochaines semaines
réponse dans 3 quarts d'heure mais
d'abord le récit de cette nouvelle
journée de guerre avec Jérôme
Rabier c'est le premier diplomate de
Auran à poser les pieds en Israël depuis
l'attaque du Hamas de samedi Anthony
blincen porte la parole américaine et
promet un soutien
indéfectible vous êtes peut-être assez
fort pour vous défendre seul mais tant
que les États-Unis existeront vous
n'aurez jamais à le faire nous serons
toujours à vos
côtés des munitions et des armes ont
déjà commencé à être acheminé vers
l'état hébreu pour un objectif clair du
gouvernement
israélien le Hamas est un État islamique
et tout comme l'état islamique a été
écrasé le Hamas sera écrasé et le Hamas
devrait être traité exactement de la
même manière que l'État islamique
au nord à proximité de la frontière
libanaise mais surtout au sud aux portes
de Gaza tsal amasse du matériel de
guerre les populations israéliennes ont
reçu l'ordre d'évacuer les villes les
plus proches laissant présager une
offensive terrestre imminente en
attendant l'ordre d'en haut l'armée
israélienne continue de pilonner ce
petit territoire dirigé par le Hamas par
la mer par les airs par le sol
l'intensité des frappes a montrer la
détermination d'Israël sur place selon
le ministère de la Santé plus de 1300
personnes sont déjà mortes dans ces
bombardement mais avec le blocus total
en eau en nourriture en gaz et en
électricité le pire est sans doute à
venir je envie de dire on va vers une
catastrophe on est déjà dans la
catastrophe mais là on va bien au-delà
de ça et on va dans une situation
humanitaire qui très vite va devenir à
mon avis ingérable selon la chaîne
américaine NBC des discussions ont lieu
sur la création d'un corridor
humanitaire vers l'Égypte qui
permettrait aux populations civil et au
blessés d'être évacuer et à des
provisions essentielles d'être livré
mais sans qu'on connaisse pour l'instant
la position du CER et d'Israël sur la
question l'offensive terrestre le sort
des otages de des grandes questions que
l'on va aborder tout de suite avec mes
invités ééonor veille bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes journaliste pour le quotidien
israélien aretz David rigouerose bonsoir
bienvenue à vous vous vous êtes
chercheur à l'Institut français
d'analyse stratégique chercheur associé
à lyis et rédacteur en chef de la revue
Orient stratégique Stéphanie lat
Abdallah bonsoir bienvenue à vous vous
êtes historienne politiste anthropologue
et chercheuse au série à Science Po et
au CNRS Émilie zapalski bonsoir Émilie
éditorialiste pour sens public je
voudrais qu'on commence peut-être on a
tous vu aujourd'hui les les images éonor
viille de de ces soldats notamment des
réservistes qui sont en train de se
masser au aux abord de la bande de Gaza
euh est-ce que ça veut dire que
l'offensive terrestre est forcément
imminente qu infos vous avez là-dessus
depuis depuis 2 TR jours on entend dans
les médias israélien régulièrement cette
idée que l'offensive terrestre devrait
arriver d'un jour à l'autre nous n'avons
pas d'autres informations ça n'a pas été
confirmé c'est l'option qui nous semble
la plus vraisemblable vous avez vu on a
vu ces images des des frappes aériennes
sur la bande de Gaza mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'aujourd'hui il y a
plus de 300000 israéliens réservistes
qui ont été mobilisés c'est même
réservist qu'il y a quelques semaines
lors des manifestations pour s'opposer
au gouvernement israélien disait qu'il
ne se mobiliserait pas comme signe de de
de contradiction d'opposition au
gouvernement israélien actuel et
aujourd'hui on voit cette mobilisation
de masse et gens qui sont qui sont prêts
à prendre du temps à risquer leur vie
parfois pour pour
aller défendre le peuple israélien et
surtout ramener le sentiment de sécurité
aux Israéliens c'est qu'il y a une sorte
de réflexe de survie de survie qui qui
s'exprime la politique les les querelles
politiques qui précédaient sont mises de
côté elles ressortiront sans doute mais
elles sont mises de côté il y a aucun
doute qu'elles ressortiront elles sont
mises de côté avec la création notamment
de ce ce ce gouvernement d'union
nationale qui va être annoncé
officiellement dans dans la soirée euh
bon on sait très bien que dans quelques
semaines dans quelques mois une fois que
que l'émotion sera retombée la politique
va va reprendre va reprendre le dessus
et il faudra à ce moment-là euh essayer
de comprendre euh qui sont les coupables
comment comment une telle horreur a pu a
pu se dérouler Israël qui se target
d'être la la l'armée la plus la plus
forte du du Moyen-Orient euh avec ce
qu'on a vu samedi soir c'est c'est voilà
c'est à remettre en question et il
faudra il faudra des réponses David
rigouet Ros ont est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer que Benjamin netanahou
attendait la constitution de ce
gouvernement d'urgence de ce cabinet de
guerre pour éventuellement on verra
déclencher l'offensive terestre oui s
sans doute parce que de toute façon euh
il sait très bien que
il y aura il y aura un diagnostic qui
devrait être fait hein ce que vous
disiez et que il sera partie prenante de
ce de cette évaluation en terme de
responsabilité donc là on est dans une
logique effectivement où il y a une
mobilisation générale de la réserve
c'est les réservistes c'est la colonne
vertébrale de Sal hein donc c'est
vraiment c'est c'est significatif qu'il
ait cet élan justement parce qu'il y a
une logique existentielle en fait qui
est sous-jacente et donc et et dans ce
cadre là il faut aussi qu'il y ait un
gouvernement qui soit du nom national
qui soit élargi pour qu' un consensus
sur les décisions très difficiles qui
vont devoir être prises ouis euh
Stéphanie latabdalla la la cible de
l'armée israélienne donnée par Ben
nenahou ou ou d'autres membres du
gouvernement d'autres vois officielles
c'est le ramasse et ses chefs
peuvent-ils et là je reste sur cette
hypothèse d'offensive terrestre
peuvent-ils les atteindre sans faire je
sais pas quel chiffre employé des
centaines des milliers de victimes
civiles si si on essaie de comprendre
comment comment Gaza est structuré oui
bah il semble que ça soit difficile h et
on on voit ici appliquer ce qui a été
appelé la la doctrine Dahier qui veut
dire banlieu qui a été appliqué depuis
la guerre du Liban de 33 jours en 2006
donc c'est la banlieu sud de beyouth et
c'est une doctrine qui vise à pilonner
en fait des infrastructures
civiles des hôpitaux et cetera
indistinctement pour en gros générer une
sorte de réaction de la population
contre éventuellement là c'était le
hbollah et là ce sera le Hamas bon on
voit très bien que cette cette
doctrine a des effets extrêmement
terribles en terme de perte humaine de
civil et en fait les les leaders du
Hamas ont tout un réseau de souterrain à
Gaza de souterrains militaires qui leur
permettent de se de se cacher ce que n'a
pas la population donc en fait par
ailleurs la prise d'otage massive a
aussi comme objectif d'avoir des sortes
de boucliers humains pour éviter qui est
justement ce ce pilonnage massif qui a
été annoncé et là on peut vraiment se
poser la question si ce gouvernement
veut vraiment protéger ses citoyens et
est en mesure de le faire citoyen
israélien quand il annonce bien qu'il y
a des tractations au coul il ne cesse
d'annoncer que de toute façon les otages
sont beaucoup moins importants que ras
et Gaza donc on se demande là des deux
côtés que cuit des civils en fait ouiile
mais les les les chefs du Hamas ils
utilisent aussi des civils pour se
protéger il y a
i Bou hum et mais aussi des civils
palestiniens ils utilisent ils se
cachent parmi la population enfin là je
cherche pas à renvoyer
ad
unecitation de la situation alors il y a
une question qui se pose est-ce que
Israël respecte le droit international
on va écouter deux témoignages d'abord
le président israélien Isaac
Herzog nous travaillons opérons militair
selon les règles du droit international
point final sans
équivoque mais nous sommes en guerre
nous sommes en guerre nous défendons nos
maisons nous protégeons nos
maisons c'est la vérité et lorsqu'une
nation protège son pays elle se bat et
nous nous battrons jusqu'à briser leur
colonne
vertébrale autre son de cloche celui du
directeur régional de la Croix-Rouge
évidemment une opinion très
différente assiéger des régions comme
Gaza plus de 2 million d'habitants qui
ont d'ailleurs déjà connu de nombreux
épisodes de
violence et tout simplement
inacceptable on peut pas viser des
civils on peut pas assiéger une zone on
ne peut pas prendre d'otage il n'y a
rien qui puisse justifier
cela Israël a été attaqué
davelle a le droit de se défendre je
pense que tout le monde est d'accord
autour de cette table est-ce qu'elle le
fait en respectant le droit
international ce qui est intéressant
c'est le discours de Joe Biden là-dessus
qui a qui a insisté justement en disant
que l'âme démocratique c'est
effectivement d'essayer dans la dans la
grande mesure du possible de respecter
des des norme et effectivement il y a il
y a en arrière-plan la problématique du
droit international humanitaire
notamment qui se pose avec la question
du siège oui et siège complet de gaz
prior n'est pas conme au dro notamment
par rapport à l'eau à l'électricité et
cetera et on retrouve justement pour
sortir de l'impasse l'option du couloir
humanitaire qui est envisagé qui
permettrait de évidemment de de
compenser ce dilemme qui se dessine
évidemment le problème c'est que les
égyptiens sont pas forcément
enthousiastes pour mettre en place ce
couloir humanitaire parce que ça
supposerait d'ouvrir le portail de Rafa
et et de voir potentiellement affluer un
nombre très très très très important de
de de de civil de de Gaza donc on voit
bien que c'est c'est une un faisceau de
contradiction en fait qui qui va être
extrêmement difficile à gérer ouais vous
vous nous parliez de du gouvernement
d'urgence et du du fait que ça devait
dans d'ci quelques minutes être
officialisé et bien dernière information
qui nous vient de no confrère de
l'Agence France Presse le chef de
l'opposition israélienne hier lapide a
accusé le gouvernement du premier
ministre netaniahou d'un échec je le
cite impardonnable pour ne pas être
parvenu à empêcher l'attaque l'échec de
samedi est impardonnable et il a ajouté
qu'il ne rejoindrait pas le gouvernement
d'urgence voilà une nouvelle nouvelle
importante comment vous l'analysez à
chaud hein à chaud écoutez c'est c'est
étonnant parce que jusqu'à il y a
quelques heures on pensait vraiment que
hier la PIST se joindrait à benigand et
rejoindrait ce gouvernement d'union
nationale mais il est vrai que les
clivages qu'il y a dans la société
israélienne depuis des mois on fait
monter la sauce et qu'aujourd'hui c'est
presque impensable de penser que ces
gens peuvent se retrouver autour d'une
table et prendre des décisions commune
et je pense que l'idée sous-jacente
c'est la peur de lè lapide d'être mêlé à
cet échec parce que il y a une
responsabilité terrible de de bamin
Tanou et de son gouvernement et que en
rejoignant ce gouvernement d'union
nationale benigand lapide les chefs de
l'opposition pourrai prendre le risque
d'être associé à ce drame et d'être
associé à cet échec militaire
sécuritaire et et du service des
renseignements également Stéphanie la
tableala ce qui ce qui apparaît aussi
alors on va pas oublier la la
responsabilité initiale évidemment du
Hamas mais c'est c'est cette sorte
d'impasse stratégique dans laquelle
Benjamin netaniaahou c'est c'est c'est
rangé bah tout à fait c'est une impasse
stratégique don je pense qu'il a pas
vraiment de pensée stratégique enfin il
en a eu une c'est-à-dire c'était faire
la paix avec les accords d'Abraham
l'Arabie Saoudite en en laissant les
Palestiniens à côté c'était ça son choix
stratégique euh c'est le seul et et
aussi empêcher toute formation d'État
palestinien c'est sa politique depuis
extrêmement longtemps et pour ça il a
favorisé le maintien du Hamas pendant de
longues années jusqu'à aujourd'hui
j'imagine sans mordre les doigts en tout
cas on peut l'espérer euh par rapport
aup pouloir imarinitaire oui par rapport
au gouvernement d'union nationale il me
semblait aussi que lapide n'était pas
trop d'accord avec le maintien de des
suprémacistes juif Benv mariich voilà et
et sinon par a priori ils ont été sortis
du gouvernement ils ont été susp alors
il y avait cette question de la de
suspendre leur fonction l voilà pour les
quelques semaines à venir ça n'a pas
encore été entériné peut-être
qu'effectivement ça a été la pierre
d'achopement peut-être que c'est ça qui
a qui a convaincu hier lapide de ne pas
rejoindre gouver
hués de gouverunion nation qui serait si
vous voulez le seul gouvernement qui
pourrait restaurer le sentiment de
sécurité et se dire que finalement la
prise de de décision ne serait pas que
entre les mains de netanahou et et de
son gouvernement et ses partis d'extrême
droite mais aussi de l'opposition et par
rapport au couloir humanitaire ça me
semble important de dire bon un couloir
humanitaire pour pourquoi parce que bon
il y a la question de effectivement
l'échange dont on parle de certains
otages notamment femmes et enfants
contre des des prisonnières et des
mineurs détenus en Israël pour des faits
mineurs il y a la question effectivement
des médicaments de la nourriture du
fouel et cetera puisque tout est bloqué
et il y a la question de faire sortir
des civils et c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose mais en tout cas les les
Égyptiens ont installé dans le Sinaï des
tentes et du matériel pour accueillir en
fait des civils donc ils sont à la fois
rétiscents et ils ont peur je pense
d'une arrivée massive mais en même temps
ils ont installé ça et je pense que
pourou parce que on parle de centaines
de milliers de personnes potentiellement
voà qui voudrait se mettre à l'abri au
moins momentanément et euh je pense
aussi que pour les PAL pour les Gazaoui
c'est évidemment une une option
nécessaire mais en même temps je pense
que c'est un traumatisme puisque 80 %
des gazai actuels sont issus sont des
réfugiés sont issus de famille de
réfugiés qui se sont réfugiés à Casa en
48 et donc ce serait comme un un début
de secondde exode bon en espérant
revenir cette fois-ci mais enfin bon il
y a je pense qu'il y a aussi ça dans
dans l'esprit alors l'une des
informations de de ce jeudi c'est le
bombardement par Israël de des deux
principaux aéroports syriens d'amass et
Halep David rigouiros comment vous
analysez ça pourquoi de de T frappe aen
qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière là on est
sur un potentiellement un autre front
qui est le le front du esbola on élargit
le focus effectivement mais on ne peut
que l'élargir parce que manifestement il
y a une une potentialogique escalatoire
et ça il y a quelques signes indicateurs
qui vont malheureusement dans ce sens-là
alorsqu bah le fait que il y a quelques
tirs au niveau de la frontière libanaise
alors pour l'instant c'est très limité
mais et puis et puis les mandataires
pro-iraniens effectivement qui sont
localisés en Syrie alors c'est pas les
sont pas les premiers bombardements de
de l'aviation israélienne en Syrie hein
ils sont récurrent justement pour
empêcher le le maintien du flux
d'armement à destination du rbola et
puis pour matraquer les les bases pro
pro-iraniennes donc c'est la peur
effectivement que il y ait euh on va
dire un agencement des pièces ce qui
était pressenti avec inquiétude par le
ministre de la Défense actuelle
c'està-dire une logique de guerre
multifront en fait d'abord avec Gaza
effectivement qui qui va qui va qui va
ancrer une partie de T autour de Gaza le
front potentiellement le front nord avec
le sudliban avec le hzbola et c'est une
autre affaire que Gaza le hzbola ça
c'est pas du tout la même la même chose
he c'est un autre morceau et puis en
terme de puissance ah oui d'abord c'est
c'est une quasi armée de hbola par qu'
n'est pas le ramasse même si c était
spectaculaire mais et puis en terme de
possibilité de de de roquette et de
missile les services israéliens estiment
que c'est de l'ordre de 100000 donc il
faut avoir ça quand on voit le résultat
de 2500 roquettes tirées par le ramas ça
ça donne un ordre de grandeur
potentielle sur les villes israéliennes
on comprend le l'inquiétude et puis et
puis il y a d'autres fronts potentiel il
y a le front des des des groupes armés
ans Jordanie qui se sont développés
depuis 2 ans et puis le le la question
tabou des 20 % d'Arabes israéliens tout
à fait euh c'est une question tabou
parce qu'évidemment c'est toujours le
syndrome de la 5e colonne dans tous les
pays qui sont concernés son confronté à
ce type de problème et c'est d'autant
plus inquiétant pour la C israélienne
qui a eu un appel de Mohamed Daif qui
est le chef de brigade elzim kassine
justementé branche armée du Hamas en
disant soutenez le la dynamique que nous
lançons et donc participer à ça alors
votre analyse sur cette idée de de 5e
colonne peut-être je commence avec vous
Stéphanie la tabdala les Arabes
israéliens j'ai pas dit qu'il pardon
j'ai pas dit qu'ils allaient le faire
bien sûr vous étiez vous égraigniez un
certain nombre d'hypothèses de ce risque
escalatoire pour reprendre votre votre
expression oui les Palestiniens d'Israël
tel qu'il se nomme plutôt maintenant
aujourd'hui eu oui bah il y a eu les
événements de Mai 2021 où il y avait eu
des affrontements et et et pour le coup
aussi beaucoup de présence de Colon s
Jordani qui sont venus aussi intervenir
en fait dans les villes où il y a
beaucoup de de de ces Palestiniens
d'Israël donc je sais pas si on peut
craindre ça je je ne le crois pas euh
par rapport à la l'extension des fronts
je je pense que c'est c'est un peu un
choix délibéré aussi de Benjamin
netanahou puisque dès lundi en fait moi
j'étais dans un une discussion sur
franceculture et il y avait une
excseiller à la défense qui disait il
est sur la table l'idée d'ouvrir le
front nord donc je suis assez étonné
ensuite de voir parce qu'au début on
avait l'impression qu'il y avait une
sorte de dissuasion par petit envoie de
roquette pour dire de la part du
hebollah pour pour dire bon on est là
mais bon voilà on bouge pas trop et
cetera et il semble qu'il y a cette
volonté alors je sais pas si on est de
l'ordre de la démonstration mais il y
avait cette volonté je pense d'ouvrir le
front nord et pour une raison à mon avis
assez simple c'est que là l'idée de
netanahou c'est de dire euh et
d'ailleurs ça a été dit c'est euh
l'Occident contre l'Iran c'est-à-dire il
veut aussi élargir la focale de
compréhension de ce conflit pour pouvoir
avoir en plus derrière lui quelque chose
d'assez massif comme soutien et je pense
que voilà je sais pas ce que ça peut
donner en terme pratique mais en tout
cas c'est je vous entends mais c'est
paradoxal d'imaginer que ce soit Israël
qui veille ouvrir un front
supplémentaire votre avis là su je peux
me permettre je me souviens très bien
des événements du du matin et ça a
commencé par une tentative
d'infiltration donc au sud l'pan au nord
du au nord d'Israël Israël a pensé à un
moment que c'était des membres du
Hezbollah et il s'est avéré que c'était
en fait des membres du jjihad islamique
et ce n'était pas du Hezbollah de là
s'en est suivi effectivement des tirs
vers le le territoire du sudliban mais
je crois que c'est erroné de penser que
c'était une tentative de provocation de
benamin netaniaahou pour élargir pour
élargir le conflit je pense que vraiment
à ce moment-là le le 99 % des des des du
du du renseignement et de l'éablissement
sécuritaire était vraiment concentré sur
le sud ils ont vu cette infiltration de
de de des membres du Djihad islamique
comme une provocation venant du nord et
voilà la la réaction la réaction de
d'Israël oui je pense qu'on peut
discuter des peut-être des détails des
faits à voir mais disons que je pense
que dans l'idée en tout cas il y a une
une grande volonté de d'utiliser ça dans
un discours je crois pas qu'il Iran
Occident qu'on entend très fortement
j'entends ce que vous dites mais je ne
pense pas que qu' qu'il ait besoin
d'utiliser quoi que ce soit je pense que
le Hamas n'aurait jamais jamais pu
organiser planifier exécuter un massacre
pareil sans l'aide de l'IR en derrière
on a vu d'ailleurs en AVR c'est pas je
je le remets pas en question ce que je
dis c'est que c'est différent de dire
bon l'Iran a aidé il a entraîné on le
sait très bien il a aidé à la
construction de à aussi avoir toutes ces
tous ces missiles faits localement et
cetera oui oui oui tout à fait on est
tout à fait d'accord là-dessus mais
c'est différent de dire ça et de dire
finalement on sont dans une nouvelle
guerre de bloc où on a l'Iran la Russie
et cetera contre l'Occident et Israël
incarnant l'Occident se défendant et en
plus avec le discours sur daesh avec un
peu tous contre daesh l'Occident contre
alors qu'en fait on sait très bien et ça
vous le savez que pendant la guerre
Syrie euh les autorités israéliennes de
l'époque ont appuyé très fortement
Al-Qaïda et daesh et ça vous le savez c
une lecture un peu rapide des fait je
pense pas qu'on puisse dire que les
autorités israéliennes les autorités
israéliennes ont appuyé certains groupes
syriens qui se
antiouvernementau des groupes
antigouvernementaux dans cela il y a
peut-être eu des membres qui ont rejoint
ensuite DAEs mais de dire qu'Israël est
est est soutenu daesh et je pense que
c'est soutenu des group armé qui on été
commis
par on peut quand même faireire cette
comparaison d'ailleurs il y a eu un
drapeau deétat islamque a été
[Musique]
retrouvé ça dépend à quel niveau vous
voulez le comparer quoi en terme oui en
terme des enants familles en terme de
pratique oui mais en terme de groupe à
quoi correspond ce groupe
non j'ai perdu
fil c'estàd que là vous avez un une
branche armée d'un parti politique qui a
aussi parti politique le Hamas mais oui
il a été élu par enfin vous savez qu'il
y a début des élection législative en
2006 qui l'ont porté au pouvoir enfin
moi je dis pas ça pour dire que c'est
formidable je dis juste ça parce que
c'est le cas donc ça relève pas de la
même chose c'est-à-dire que c'est
quelqu'un qui a le Hamas a un discours
national nationaliste alors oui avec des
méthodes je ne parle pas des méthodes
j'essaie juste terrorisme de des pratiqu
de terroriste oui mais ça ne change rien
au fait internation oui mais ça ne
change rien pour moi ce sont des crimes
de guerre avec des pratiques terroristes
mais peu importe c'est un débat très
très long impor non je reviens sur cette
histoire de de montrer cette
détermination parce que on sent ça aussi
dans le gouvernement israélien cette
volonté de frapper très fort dans les
mots avec ce siège de de la bande de gaz
d'aller très très loin dans cet état
d'esprit on entend le porte-parole du
gouvernement qui dit bah de toute façon
les otages oui les otages mais on va
faire en parallèle c'est-à-dire qu'on va
attaquer et on va essayer de récupérer
des otage on va très loin dans cette
rhétorique et probablement aussi en
rejoignant votre idée de dire c'est
c'est tous contre c'est terroristes moi
je rappis le terme en tout cas le Hamas
euh il y a cet espritlà de taper très
fort mais après euh on ne peut pas
savoir déterminé ce qu'il y a qui va
réellement être en acte et ce qui est de
l'ordre de la rhtorique pour faire peur
et être à la hauteur puisque comme vous
le disiait le gouvernement est en
faiblesse sur sa réaction en tout cas
son action jusque-là donc c'est pour
marquer le coup jusqu'à quel point il
passera à l'action réellement et ça peut
s'embraser bon comme vous disiez il y a
des signaux qui montrent que ça peut
être assez ferme alors on va justement
ouvrir la la question des otages avec
d'abord ce bilan côté français qui s'est
encore alourdi aujourd'hui on parle de
12 morts et 17 disparu selon toute
vraisemblance autage du du ramas peut-on
imaginer des négociations autour des 150
à 200 personnes retenu par les
terroristes palestiniens je propose à
Tam tranui de de nous rejoindre tout de
suite bonsoir bienvenue à vous on va
commencer par la position du
gouvernement français sur cette question
la position du gouvernement français
elle a été donnée hier par la chef de la
diplomatie française Catherine Colona il
n'y a aucune voix de négociation entre
la France et les terroristes écoutezla
chez nos confrères de franceino hier
évidemment nous demandons la libération
immédiate et sans conditions des
Français qui seraient détenu en otage
par le Hamas nous sommes tout à fait
confiants dans la capacité des autorités
israéliennes à nous aider du mieux
possible à faire que les personnes de
nationalité française qui auraient
disparu puissent être retrouvé puissent
être libéré saine et sauve et nous
redemandons leur libération jour après
jour aucune négociation directe donc
avec le Hamas nous dit le quoret mais
une diplomatie française qui s'en remet
à Israël et qui multiplie également nous
dit la ministre les contacts avec les
pays de la région comme le Qatar qui
s'est rapidement proposé d'agir comme
médiateur dans cette crise cette
position on la retrouve également en
Allemagne ne pas négocier directement
mais prendre contact dans la région
alors c'est pas le cas de tous les pays
certains ont commencé à négocier Erdogan
notamment le président turc a lancé un
processus de négociation avec le Hamas
c'est ce qu' a indiqué mercredi une
source officielle à l'Agence France
Presse sans plus de détails hein sur
l'avancée des pour parler sur les otages
il y a également pour le coup ce n'est
pas un pays mais le comité
internationale de la Croix-Rouge qui est
lui en contact avec le Hamas et les
autorités israéliennes pour tenter de
libérer les otages c'est ce qu'il a
indiqué par communiqué aujourd'hui je le
cite en notre qualité d'intermédiaire
neutre nous nous tenons prêt à effectuer
des visites humanitaires à aider les
otages et leurs familles à maintenir le
contact ainsi qu'à faciliter toute
libération explique la Croix-Rouge qui a
précisé aujourd'hui lors d'un point
presse nous parlons tous les jours nous
poussons mais nous ne négocions pas
comprendre et ils ne font pas d'offre
d'échange de prisonniers alors justement
est-ce qu'Israël pourrait pratiquer des
échanges de de prisonniers pour obtenir
cette libération des hôeles c'est ce qui
s'est fait par le passé en 30 ans hein
c'est le compte du chercheur Étienne Gua
l'État d'Israël a libéré près de 7000
prisonniers pour obtenir en échange la
libération de 19 israéliens le cas le
plus célèbre est celui du soldat Gilad
chalid dont la Libération a été négociée
avec le Hamas en échange de 1027
prisonniers longtemps la libération des
otages a donc été la priorité absolue
cette fois-ci et bien difficile
d'imaginer de tels échanges de telles
concession vu le nombre d'otagees qui a
été retenu par le Hamas Israël semble
aussi être pour l'instant davantage sur
une ligne de fermeté et sur l'idée de ne
pas céder au chantage dans ce contexte
on peut se poser aussi une question le
rôle des opinions publiques par exemple
en France on a vu une pétition signée
par près de 50000 personnes dont de
nombreuses personnalités du monde du
spectacle des politiques qui demandent
actuellement la libération immédiate
inconditionnale des otages civiles on
peut douter de son efficacité auprès du
Hamas parce que l'on a vu beaucoup
aujourd'hui aussi ce sont les proches
des otages qui se sont mobilisés qui ont
témoigné dans les médias avec notamment
aujourd'hui une conférence de presse à
Londres une conférence de presse aussi
sur les otages israéliens et français
franco-israéliens objectif là encore
mobiliser l'opinion publique israélienne
pour plaider la cause des otages auprès
du pouvoir public israélien ce qui on
peut l'imaginer a davantage de poids oui
et puis alors merci beaucoup Tami a eu
aussi une conférence de presse des
otages francoisraéliens avec un appel
lancé à Emmanuel Macron pour faire
libérer le leur proches David R douerose
sauf que quand on entend ça enfin on
comprend leur réaction mais que peut
faire un président français dans un tel
contexte bah peu de choses en réalité
c'est le problème c'estàd que c'est
largement on peut tout à fait comprendre
évidemment les les attentes he des
familles parce que c'est c'est
insupportable mais en même temps on voit
pas très bien ce que pourrait faire la
France qui de toute mais c'est
d'ailleurs pas seulement le cas de la
France c'est le cas de beaucoup de pays
qui ont des ressortissants
qui ont été qui ont fait l'objet du
effectivement de d'un enlèvement il y a
des Américains il y a des il y a des
Français il y a des Européens d'autres
Européens donc c'est en réalité c'est
c'est le paradoxe der la situation c'est
qu'il a de fait une internationalisation
en fait de la question de la
problématique des otages c'est pas
uniquement des des B nationaux il y a
les B nationaux et puis il y a voilà
donc c'est très très compliqué c'est on
n'est pas du tout dans une configuration
classique comme ça a pu être le cas par
le passé notamment avec l'archétype le
modèle entre guillemets la négociation
pour G Chalit qui avait duré faut le
rappeler plusieurs années bien sûr et on
n'est pas là dans un tempo si vous
voulez o où il va où on peut se
permettre entre guillemets d'attendre
donc et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il y
a pas une communication excessive des
autorités sur la question des otages
parce qu'on sait très bien que dans la
profondeur de la société israélienne bon
en culture juive la vie n'a pas de prix
et là on se retrouve dans un dilemme
cornéen en sachant qu'il y a des
impératifs stratégiques qui ne qui ne
qui vont imp un certain nombre de
décisions très douloureuses ce qui ne
veut pas dire qu'ils vont être
abandonnés il y aura des certainement
des opérations des forces spéciales mais
avec des résultats plus qu'uncertains et
qui ne remettront pas en cause justement
le déroulement de l'opération à venir
est-ce qu'on peut imaginer parce que
hier sur ce plateau on avait la
journélim qui parlait de de de d'unité
de force spécial américaine qui était
sur le le sol isralien est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer que cert que des force spécial
vous avez peut-être pas réponse à la
question mais voilà mais mais pourrait
participer à une opération comme C c'est
le le problème c'est le modèle d'antb en
réalité de 76 mais qui était un cas très
particulier exceptionnel d'ailleurs éco
écoinist de l'histoire c'est le frère
aîné de Benjamin netaniaahou qui était
qui avait organisé
réussiéuss et qui est un qui est mort
lors de cette
opération vous nous parliez hon
norveille de de de ces 300000
réservistes qui pour certains
manifestaient contre la politique de
benyami netanahou il y a il y a quelques
jours ou quelques semaines est-ce que on
peut dire que pour majorité d'Israéliens
la vengeance aujourd'hui pèse plus lourd
que les otages que le sort des otages
alors je pense que c'est c'est c'est
dangereux de dire ça et c'est pas tout à
fait juste et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que l'option d'une invasion terrestre
est de plus en plus probable c'est
justement cette invasion terrestre elle
a pour objectif de d'essayer de
retrouver ces otages ce qui est
évidemment très risqué l'opinion
publique dans le passé a été pour au
compte s'est exprimé de manière très
clivée autour de cette question de
l'invasion terrestre parce qu'on sait
que une invasion terrestre c'est des
pertes en vie humaines aussi du côté du
côté israélien mais dire aujourd'hui que
la vengeance est plus importante que
retrouver les les les otages non je
pense qu'on on peut pas dire ça ce qui
est sûr c'est que il faut bien
comprendre que que le pays dans un
effroid dans une terreur dans un choc
terrible depuis depuis ce samedi que
Israël n'avait jamais vécu ça même
depuis sa création et
qu'aujourd'hui l'opinion publique
israélienne le gouvernement tout le
monde est en choc et tout le monde
attend des réponses à tant des actions
dans la bande de Gaza vous parliez du
corridor humanitaire je propose un
élément pour pour relancer le le
chapitre autour de ce thème le
porte-parole du Conseil de sécurité
nationale américain John Kirby qui donne
des des détails sur ce qui serait
possible on
l'écoute vous êtes nombreux à poser des
questions ou à manifester de l'intérêt
pour l'idée d'un couloir humanitaire à
Gaza pour les civils permettez-moi de
dire d'emblé que nous en discutons
activement avec nos homologues is
israélien et égyptiens nous sommes
favorables à un couloir humanitaire pour
les civils les civils ne sont pas
responsables de ce que le Hamas a
fait je ne peux pas vous indiquer une
route ou un corridor spécifique je veux
simplement préciser que nous travaillons
activement sur cette question avec nos
homologues égyptiens et
israélien alors vous avez commencé à en
parler tout à l'heure Stéphanie ldall
mais je veux bien qu'on creuse un peu
cette thématique là est-ce que c'est
l'Égypte qui détient la clé bah l'Égypte
détient une partie de la clé et
notamment dans le cadre de transaction
sur cette question des otages et des
libérations l'Égypte a beaucoup de
levierers puisque elle tient le le point
de passage de Rafa au sud de la bande de
Gaza bien qu'il ait été bombardé je
pense qu'il y a quand même moyen de
faire passer des gens et donc elle tient
à la
fois si elle coopère elle accepte le
siège total ou bien elle lève ce siège
total elle a les moyens de le faire et
elle a donc aussi un moyen de pression
sur le Hamas puisque il va se retrouver
lui aussi asphixier enfin la bande de
Gaza et et le Hamas derrière il
évidemment le Qatar aussi qui a des
leviers puisque c'est c'est vraiment le
le financeur aujourd'hui de la bande de
Gazin hein c'est le seul qui qui
quasiment qui amène suffisamment
d'argent il y a l'Allemagne qui quoi
qu'elle dise euh et un peu sur ces
questions aussi active euh parce qu'elle
a une tradition aussi de d'interposition
et de négociation dans les questions
relatives aux échanges de prisonniers
bien sûr la Turquie et le CISR donc
quand on dit que la la France ne peut
rien faire effectivement je pense que là
la nationalité des otages importe peu
enfin en tout cas pour ceux qui les ont
pris par contre la France peut
effectivement se rapprocher de ces pays
et interagir à partir de là pour essayer
de voir s'il s'agit de les libérer quel
type de transaction peuvent être faites
mais de toute façon vous parliez de ça
fait 10 ans qu'en fait il y a des
tractations entre le Hamas et les
autorités israéliennes
pour aboutir à un échange de prisonniers
en fait le Hamas veut faire sortir
beaucoup de prisonniers dont nombre de
leaders du Hamas et pas seulement des
leaders comme Marwan Bargou
notamment comme Ahmad Saadat du Front
Populaire de Libération de la Palestine
et il veut les échanger contre comme
vous le savez il y a deux israéliens qui
se sont infiltrés à Gaza un d'origine
égyptienne et un Bédoin et deux corps de
soldats morts pendant la guerre de 2014
donc en fait cette histoire
transactionnelle elle dure et jusque- là
elleaboutit pas et là elle est remise
alors effectivement avec tous ces aotage
et je pense que oui l'Égypte les
services de renseignement égyptiens ont
toujours été les intermédiaires de ces
et de ses négociation Marwan bargouti
vous en parlez il est il est en prison
depuis plus de 20 ans euh et et dans son
intervention ce matin sur France Inter
l'ancien ministre des Affaires
étrangères ancien Premier ministre aussi
Dominique de Villepin évoquit son cas
tout en parlant de la question de une
solution à deux États qui
cohabiteraient nous devons penser parce
que j'en suis convaincu aujourd'hui
devant vous plus que jamais que la
solution à deux états qu'on a enterré
j'étis heureux d'entendre Catherine
Colona hier sur France Info la solution
à deux états plus que jamais est
aujourd'hui la seule et il faut avoir le
courage il faut avoir le courage faisons
en sorte qu'émerge faisons en sorte
qu'émerge une Autorité palestinienne qui
soit représentative et capable de mener
des négociations et de ce point de vue
là Israël a une responsabilité car a
tout fait pour
diviserinalis Mahmoud bargouti il est en
prison depuis des années et et il aurait
pu être un des chef alternatif sans
doute mieux que beaucoup d'autres et
nous voyons bien que la solution à deux
états c'est pas seulement une solution
politique qui est la seule aujourd'hui
mais c'est aussi en terme de sécurité la
meilleure garanti que pourrait avoir
Israël car avoir un état constitué à
côté de soi ça vaut mieux que d'avoir un
pululement d'organisation terroriste un
chaudron mortifère qui vous menace à
chaque instant alors ça semble illusoire
ce soir David rigolerose mais il faut
quand même se poser la question de de de
l'après quel interlocuteur pourrait un
être un je sais pas un négociateur ou un
homme de paix est-ce qu'un Marwan
margouti peut devenir un homme de paix
après 20 ans passé en prison oui
d'ailleurs Marwan margouti n'a rien à
voir avec le ramas hein à la limite il
préfère faire libérer des membres du
Hamas que que lui hein tout simplement
parce qu'il est lié à l'autorité enfin
au f Il il est très haut sur la liste
depuis longtemps oui mais c'est c'est
pas leur priorité c'est pas leur
priorité parce que non mais si on
cherche des interlocuteur vous voyez ce
que je veux dire si on se projette et
encore une fois c'est pas le moment mais
ça c'est c'est pas du tout d'actualité
malheureusement c'est il aurait fallu ce
soit avant parce que là la séquence qui
s'ouvre permettra pas du tout ce type de
choses et et c'est ça le le le drame de
la situation c'estàdire que
effectivement le viati des deux États
qui est
d'ailleurs la proposition depuis la fin
enfin depuis 1947 hein donc c'est c'est
le problème c'est que sur le terrain
elle est de moins en moins viable c'est
ça qui est qui est tragique du fait de
la politique de coisation et d'un
ensemble de paramètres avec des deux
côtés une radicalisation une
extrémisation qui font que ceux qui
pourraient discuter des deux d'une
certaine manière se retrouve finalement
sans voie quasiment sans presque
marginalisé d'une certaine faç bah parce
que effectivement il y a une indexation
du du conflit sur l'extrémisme des deux
bords et c'est ça qui est dramatique
enorveille avec une information qui
concerne l'extrême droite dans dans les
tractations entre Benjamin netanahou et
et ses ministres y a quoi à la création
d'une d'une espèce de milice privée
c'est ça vous pouvez nous expliquer ce
qui est en train de se passer alors la
création de la milice privée elle
existait elle existait déjà c'est itamer
benvier qui en a été qui est le ministre
de la Sécurité Nationale qui en a été
responsable et c'est vrai qu'on on
reproche d'ailleurs beaucoup à à bami
netaniaahou d'avoir vraiment concentrer
ses efforts avec son gouvernement sur la
sis-jordanie de vouloir annexer les
territoires de s-jordanie et de vouloir
justement mettre cette question au
centre au centre du débat et ne pas
s'être concentré sur ce qui se passait
dans le sud et et et dans la bande de
Gaza cette milice privée c'est une
milice qui est qui qui n'existait pas
avant ce ce gouvernement et qui a vu le
jour pour justement s'occuper de la
sisjordanie et on a vu les les dégâts
qu'elle a causé ces derniers mois h euh
on on va parler pour terminer il nous
reste quelques minutes dans ce débat de
la question des des images et c'est vrai
que pour nous aussi observateurs la la
semaine est est rude quand on regarde
les images qui qui parviennent du Proche
Orient Émilie vous avez été interpellé
par les propos d'Alain beer concernant
justement ces images oui même par son
émotion le criminologue était interviewé
hier matin sur BFM TV et ces mots m'ont
marqué ces silences aussi pourtant on
peut imaginer qu'il a dû envoir des des
images atroces depuis le début de sa
carrière mais c'est vrai qu'hier il a
tout simplement dit qu'il aurait préféré
ne pas voir ces vidéos issues des
massacres et notamment celle qui
concerernit les enfants et l'homme
conseille même il va un peu plus loin
que que son travail il dit il faut
conseiller les parents qui ont des
enfants ou des adoles desent de faire
peur de pédagogie pour ces images soit
par la gestion donc peut-être expliqué
soit par l'interdiction et le tout pour
éviter des éventuel traumatisme alors
c'est d'autant plus important qu'il y a
effectivement une on va dire une
circulation dé multiplié de ces c'est
active hein oui il y a une
multiplication de photos de vidéos qui
sont assez monstrueuses ça risque de se
poursuivre he parce que c'est ça
participe aussi à une espèce de de
propagande de guerre WhatsApp TikTok
telegram pour ne citer que relais sans
interruption des images et qui même
flouté peuvent choquer et qui font des
millions de vues he on voit ça et
au-delà du travail de vérification des
informations transmises he évidemment ce
travail de de fake news bah il faut
savoir comment on peut se protéger de
ces images choc alors il y a la
Commission européenne qui travaille
dessus hein elle a fait un digital
service Act adopté en juillet 2022
l'idée c'est d'essayer de mieux encadrer
la modération des réseaux sociaux
notamment mais en même temps on a x ex
Twitter qui décide de publier siamment
certains de ses compes contenu et
l'entreprise elle assume même totalement
cette idée làà cette position elle
l'explique dans un tweet qui a été
publié le 10 octobre nous savons qu'il
est parfois très difficile de voir
certains contenus surtout dans le
contexte actuel dans ces situations x
estime que bien que cela soit difficile
il est dans l'intérêt public de
comprendre ce qu'il se passe en temps
réel oui bien sûr x on le rappelle de
moins en moins de modérateurs et puis
c'est dans le modconom décision
complètement assumé que voilà sur
l'intérêt public soit partagé bref c'est
pas la première fois que cette question
ça évidemment les attentats de de
Charlie Hebdo du 13 novembre la
décapitation de Samuel Patis aette
question là de l'impact des images et de
cette circulation était déjà là pour le
Bataclan il faut se souvenir que le
ministère de l'Intérieur avait essayé de
bloquer l'accès aux photos les plus
choquantes enfin de laisser Twitter de
faire circuler ses photos mais en 20ain
et la diffusion des vidéos de
l'intérieur de la salle de concert dans
le cadre du procès avait aussi fait
polémique c'était diffusé pendant les
audiences et certaines parties civil
avaient dit qu'elle ne souhaitait pas du
tout assister à ça alors que d'autres
considéraent que c'était de leur devoir
qu'ell devaient ça à leur pre décéd et
peut-être que c'est ça la clé en fait
c'est de se dire qu'il faut se donner
tous les moyens pour se laisser le choix
est-ce que je veux visualiser ou pas
protéger évidemment les plus sensibles
et les plus jeunes parce que on peut se
dire que quand même ces images même si
elles sont choquantes et quand elles
sont vérifiées elles ont quand même leur
utilité h Stéphanie la table d'as pardon
de revenir sur le le comparatif entre le
Hamas et et daesh mais l'utilisation des
images de de hor reur c'est aussi un
très commun oui alors moi sur les images
je voilà je je serais pour le moment
précautionneuse on a besoin de vérifier
on a vu un article du Monde qui a
démonté certains fausses images je dis
pas qu'elles sont toutes fausses au loin
de là je ne remets pas en question les
atrocités loin de là je suis choquée
comme tout le monde je dis juste que
pour moi qui suis historienne euh et
poli j'attends qu'on puisse voir voilà
ce qui est de ses images et comment on
peut travailler dessus comment on peut
les voir les voir ça changerait votre
perception du ramass mais enfin vous
croyez que j'ai quoi comme je sais pas
par que vos propos me me troublent non
mais en fait que vous le fait de ne pas
vouloir qualifier les actes de
terroriste imaginer
compais j'ai pas du tout dit ça j'ai pas
du tout dit ça en fait c'est non
c'estàdire que moi je considère que
l'acte ce qu'il provoque c'est de la
terreur et en ce sens c'est du
terrorisme en revanche je pense que le
Hamas ne n'est pas le même type
d'organisation quand on analyse qu'une
organisation comme daesh il y a une
différence entre les actes perpétré et
l'organisation qui les perpètre c'est
tout mais oui il y a une différence oui
mais c'est de nature terroriste même si
c'est pas la même chose que oui mais
vous comprenez oui mais vous comprenez
bien où se situe mon analyse elle se
situe pas du tout dans les actes qui
sont perpétrés mais de qui perpétre ses
actes mais qui c'est le ramas ENF je
comprends pas en fait la distinction que
vous vous établissez entre le ramas et
entre les qui on été comprenez pas la
distinction entre un groupe avec une une
idéologie globale apocalyptique et et un
au départ un parti politique qui s'est
constitué qui a été qui a été qui a été
élu en 2000 en
2006 voilà enfin c'est pas du tout le
même la même structure en fait
bonme oui mais enfin enfin aujourd'hui
non ils ont amandé la charte mais peu
importe pe impor mais peu importe le
sujet n'est pas là en fait je pense que
je pense que la différ ent nous c'est
que moi je me situe au niveau vraiment
de l'analyse de qu'est-ce que c'est ce
groupe et là je suis pas dans le
jugement moral oui mais ça n'empêche pas
que que les actes sont des actes de
terreur en fait
je on parle de fait de définition c'est
extrêmement important de rappeler que le
Rama c'est une organisation terroriste
je va pas voilà qui est reconnu comme
tel par les États-Unis et l'Union
européenne mais ça ça c'est c'est un
détail ce qui s'est passé samedi soir
vous pouvez pas le distinguer de
l'organisation ça a été effectué
perpétré par le Hamas qui svenu par les
par les le je me réfère juste à
l'histoire du de ce de ce mouvement en
fait je pense qu'il faut que vous vous
juste vous preniez en compte que moi
j'ai une analyse d'historienne là-dessus
et point et et là je suis pas sur la
question morale et je vlais répéter pour
moi moralement ce sais les actes de TER
comment en tant qu'histtorienne on peut
déplacer la question morale elle fait
partie de l'histoire aussi la question
morale bah écoutez peut-être que vous
n'êtes pas historienne non je ne suis
pas historien voilà VO allez on va
terminer le débat là-dessus merci euh à
tous d'y avoir participé David rigouet
rose on vous lit dans la revue Orient
stratégique et laonor veille dans le
quotidien aretz merci beaucoup d'avoir
participé à ce débat